what I'd say is I'm first of all I'm
really sad and I'm disappointed about
the disruption that has been caused to
so many people's lives particularly at
Christmas time you know when it comes to
it's because it's a difficult question
of setting public sector pay the
government has acted fairly and
reasonably in accepting all the
recommendations of the public sector pay
review bodies that's an independent
process the government has listened to
you know I urge everybody who's
traveling at the moment to just please
check before you make your journey so
you know what's happening you're risking
a dangerous escalation though aren't you
you're obviously trying to hold your
nerve with the unions but the fact that
more strike dates have been announced is
a sign of failure right you know what
what I'm trying to do is make the right
long-term decisions for the country for
everybody's benefit and I think we all
know that the major economic challenge
we all face now is inflation it's
inflation that's eating into everyone's
pay packets and Rising the cost of
living and I want to make sure that we
reduce inflation part of that is being
responsible when it comes to setting
public sector pay that's why we have an
independent process I know things are
difficult but it's right that there's an
independent body that makes
recommendations to the government and
the government accepted those that it
increased its offer matched all those
recommendations I think that's the
reasonable thing to do and in the long
term it's the right thing for the whole
country that we beat inflation are you
ruling out a one-off payoff there's a
great deal of sympathy when it comes
including from Tory voters to NHS
workers striking are you ruling out a
one-off payoff for that you know I'm
really grateful to all our public sector
workers including those in the NHS with
a fantastic job they they do for us and
as the health secretary and I have
previously said our door is always open
you know the government's always wanting
to talk to people to engage with them
about you know what we can do to make
sure that their jobs are fulfilling
rewarding there's lots of things that
people have raised as things that we
might make a difference to and we'd be
happy to talk about all those things and
health secretary has been clear his door
the government's door is always open to
have those talks